welcome to this video be honest be
honest idealist yep and from from Greece
let's see let's see fianchetto king's
indian guru thought they know only what
to see aiming for most Kings Indian
players would have okay so all this kind
of stuff probably going to a symmetrical
english knight c6 I can also go d 6
that's this kind of this kind of a line
that's funny never saw that one okay I
already don't know let's just play
quickly here
okay Quinn a fire maybe let's not make a
huge fuss out about it just play play
quickly and with normal normal-looking
move well that's not a normal-looking
move getting right into 93 and and stuff
okay let's protect this threat 93 or is
the move like Nigeria show he just plays
it okay look d 1 first maybe I an assist
this 93 he will take everything off
there's also no night move about the
weird situation
that's really really strange look 21
days what Quincy 6
I know that's really weird no is going
there yeah i was thinking that here i
have to shoot you for actually which is
nothing great but at least
then you form but what a wiki game
come on it can be serious what are you
doing it to me edits that's really great
like Age 3 now or what I cannot move the
night Bishop g7 there is this it takes f
you takes f maybe that's even maybe
that's employer come on that's all
totally weird okay so h3 takes their age
three takes a three takes g4 and for
taking that don't take it with the pony
can take c5 with the queen with check
what kind of what kind of stuff is
happening here check
be to us hanging age three hangs but
okay I have to have to take that one
water whatever I don't know taking age
three now maybe you can do it there's no
at least I don't see any direct
refutation of that tragic possibly night
284 yeah that would be nice I'm not sure
how with this equal material and
94 is 94 is a slight issue
so what is he doing on f5 mmm five is
really really weakening even rook takes
b7 as a move okay let's let's still be
aggressive here c-5m just activate all
pieces he has a hard time to move stuff
they are route v6 I could be displaced
misplace check here and I don't know I
need to be quick here is the chick and I
thought I thought there's also write a
for simply now let's do that simply
threatening to take twice them ok I'm
going to do that
I let so that's a funny funny way takes
with the chick chick okay
time morning I check on fi if you had
taking on age three I this this this
ridiculous game yeah what is this game I
don't understand any of it no man they
had it under control them again yes this
is a check I'm going to take this what
are you doing no man resigns hey there
are the totally bonkers game the whole
game was totally weird I mean it started
with 25 this is hard to believe there
may be it is it's playable that's
putting it right in the center looks
really bad I mean there was this I mean
I saw that but I thought yeah yet 94
though man this is just like a couple of
Tempe up for white so it should be quite
good but yeah then this is this is just
a good move yeah what can you do it's
moving the same piece twice everything
and still good it is just good for black
in five four yeah oops sorry I was so
what's the wrong button this was good
for black but he also could have taken I
was thinking that this isn't that clear
but of course not Jack I thought that
this might be something that I can play
but Bishop cakes and it's just it's just
better for like there is no no move here
really what a weird game yeah and here
I'm just and in this is just a row any
others position
gage and somehow I got back into it with
with good play and then screwed it up
again like here I hear this is this is
strong and taking only six next to this
kind of thing because I'm winning the
queen with this kind of a deal ok and
here yet this great resource I cannot
take I can but check so I cannot pick up
the bishop so and then I over look at
the screen f5 business now no I'm lost
certainly and then I don't know what
what happened here Bishop c4 hey
overlooked that is a check I mean like a
snake just winning here my king is like
in the open King twin age six strong
pointed out by the engine intending work
T to ya and lost ur he just blundered
everything at the end I don't know what
happened there well at least it was may
be entertaining thanks for watching